all right we can now do the math to
solve for V so let me just simplify the
right-hand side of this equation V -
negative V well that's just going to be
2 V + 1 minus negative of V squared over
C squared well that's just 1 plus
positive V squared over C squared and
let's see what can we do next well we
can multiply we're going to want to
solve for V we can multiply both sides
of this equation by 1 plus V squared
over C squared so let's do that 1 plus V
squared over C squared on the right hand
side those cancel on the left hand side
we can distribute the 0.8 and we will
get 0.8 or we can distribute the 0.8 C I
should say 0.8 C plus 0.8 C V squared
over C squared
well the C of the numerator is going to
cancel with one of these C's in the
denominator so it's going to be plus 0.8
V squared over C and then is going to be
equal to 2 V and remember we want to
solve for V so we're setting up
essentially a quadratic in V so let's
now move let's now find ourselves give
ourselves some real estate so let's go
right over there let's subtract 2v from
both sides and actually I'm going to
write it in order of degree so on the
left hand side I have 0.8 I'll write
that over C V squared and then minus 2 V
I just subtracted 2v from both sides
plus 0.8 C plus 0.8 C is equal to 0 I
guess we want to simplify a little bit
we can multiply both sides by C I don't
that'll well let me just go with that if
we multiply both sides by C this will
become 0.8 V squared minus 2 C V plus
0.8 C squared is equal to 0 and we could
keep trying to algebraically manipulate
this but we could just go straight to
the quadratic formula here to solve
4v I'll do that in a different color
just for kicks V is going to be equal to
negative B so this right over here is B
and write this down this is our B this
is our a and this is our C we're talking
about the coefficient or we're talking
about the different variables using the
quadratic formula
so V is going to be negative B so the
negative of negative 2 C so it's going
to be 2 C plus or minus the square root
of b squared so negative 2 C squared is
positive 4 C squared minus 4 times a so
minus 4 times 0.8 times C so times 0.8 C
squared 0.8 C squared all of that over
2a so 0.8 times 2 is 1.6 let's see this
is going to be equal to 2 C plus or
minus the square root now let's see I
can factor out a 4 C squared 4 C squared
times 1 minus 0.8 times 0.8 is 0.6 for
all ideas I factored out a 4 C squared
from both terms of course all of that
over 1.6 scroll down a little bit and
this is going to be equal to it this is
all algebra at this point to see plus or
minus if I fact if I take the 4 C
squared out of the radical it's going to
be it's going to be 2 C so 2 C plus or
minus 2 C times the square root of 1
minus 0.64 well that's 0.36
things are getting nicely simple now all
over 1.26
the square root of 0.36 the principal
root of that is 0.6 so that's 0.6 and
move down a little bit so this is going
to be equal to 2 C and I can I can see
the end plus or minus two times zero
point six is 1.2 C all of that over one
point six so we've got two possible
values for V what we can tell
if we add if we do the plus up here
you're going to end up with 3.2 C
divided by one point six which is going
to be a speed a velocity of greater than
the speed of light so we can rule out
the positive version of it so we know
the answer is going to have to be the
negative version of it so to see minus
1.2 C over one point six which is equal
to 0.8 C over one point six well zero
point eight is half of one point six so
this is zero point five see that was
really really really cool because what's
what what do we know now we know now
that if a in a frame of reference a
feels like it is stationary
we have A's friend moving with a
relative velocity of eight tenths of the
speed of light there could be a third
party see that defines a frame of
reference moving away from a with the
velocity of half the speed of light half
the speed of light and from a frame of
reference it looks like C's velocity is
closer to bees than it is to ace but
we're dealing in this relativistic this
this this this Einstein Ian's world
because if we then go into C's frame of
reference it actually looks like a and B
are both leaving C with a speed of 0.5 C
zero so here you can view the velocity
is positive 0.5 C and here you could say
the velocity is negative 0.5 negative
0.5 C this was really cool we're able to
find a frame of reference that you could
think of it is right in between and
what's going to be really cool about
this is that we can actually you know
what what some people don't like about
Minkowski space-time diagrams is that it
looks asymmetric even though if B is
moving in a stream of reference with a
velocity of positive eight tenths of the
speed of light well then if you were in
B's frame of reference a is moving to
the left with a speed of 0.8 times C but
now we can define another I guess you
could say a neutral frame of reference
where they're both moving in different
directions with the same speed which may
actually makes the the the interpreting
the space-time diagram a little bit
easier we will do that in future videos
but this is a fun problem in a
it's in an on itself